i have with me roland montagne of idate
roland your company was behind some
significant developments a major
announcement today biggest growth in
fdth for five years give us the
highlights exactly we have the chance to
be selected by the fth council europe
for measuring the ftth market and this
year we delivered the panorama for
handoff last year 2014 and then we have
this announcement
there is a growth of 60
in terms of ftth subscribers in
political europe u28 it is the best
growth since 2010. that is amazing and i
think two countries really stood out
exactly we have two countries really
leading the league in terms of growth we
have a russia russia being very strong
because of the settle of population in
mdus in building and in western europe
we have spain spain really progressed a
lot in terms of rollout with
telefonica the incumbent but also in
terms of adoption what was the main
success in russia who was the main sort
of
person really pushing russians russia's
development well in fact
in russia you have a settlement of the
population in large ndus
and this is a good point when you are
looking at the business model of fiber
to the home you just put a five at the
basement of the building and then you
can address all the building one point
the other point is the bad quality of
copper also so if people don't have a
lot of bandwidth over copper they will
switch quite easily
to fiber to the whole i see and spain's
success has enabled it to grow quite a
lot in the league table it sort of
jumped up quite a level hasn't it in
terms of provision
exactly today telefonica is the only
incumbent in europe presenting 10
million home past this is huge in a
little time to do that but you can see
the same reason a little bit because
also in spain a lot of the population
are living in mdus for the moment
telefonica is targeting this mdu and
they prefer to bet in a future-proof
technology ftth instead of investing in
a cop that is not so good also
in spain
why has there been such a significant
jump this year what are the what's the
key factors behind this
well i think that uh
main players
are today confident in the fiber
technology
they are saying maybe it's time for me
to invest
one time in a future proof technology
better to invest several times on
several steps in copper technology such
as
vectoring or vdsl if i don't have a very
good copper network like it is maybe the
case in the uk or in germany or in
belgium my interest is to invest once
but in a future-proof technology
and are there new dynamics affecting the
market as well
exactly we see today
new entrants in the fiber market
uh all the ecosystem is trying to push
the investment fund
for deploying ftth and if you see some
examples
in european countries for example in
student with ipo only
in the netherlands with the cif you see
some funds today investing in ftth
network and this is a very good sign we
believe that in the years to come we'll
have more and more willingness of these
funds to help in the deployment of fiber
well and this is great news thanks very
much for joining us thank you very much
so a very significant moment in the
develop of ftth right across europe